next thing that's very important to me
is that we build a smart football team
that we have a smart football team here
and i know we have the the people in
place to do that
the first part of that the first part of
being smart is knowing what to do
we're gonna we're gonna know we're gonna
have systems
in place that are easier to learn
all right complicated to the defense or
offense that they're going against or
the special teams group they're going
against
but easy for us to learn because when we
can put that because we
when we can learn our system and we can
get good at our system
then our talent can take over less
thinking equals talent take over but we
need to
have systems in place and we will have
systems in place
to do so
all right this is this is a difficult
one for me
but look i i wrote about this
on friday night inspired by siriani's
effort to read from whatever it was he
was trying to read from and earlier in
the day or later in the day it was
siriani first and then the texans
afterward nick casario reading from
a sheet of paper like it was a book
report in seventh grade
right i don't understand it chris
i don't get it we're talking about
especially in the case of siriani this
is a guy
who's going to be commanding a locker
room this is a guy
who is making his first impression
on the philadelphia fan base
and also those players in the locker
room
who have never played for him before and
don't know him this is his introduction
to them
how are these billion dollar businesses
that have the resources and the
incentive
to get the help they need to get
guys ready to properly show up
stand at a podium and speak from the
heart
it's not that hard and i know well you
do it every day
it's not that hard that's why we have
the jobs
it's not that hard you just talk you say
what you believe
you say who you are it's not what you
say
right it's not like and and i'll give
you an example i always aspired when i
was practicing law
to be able to deliver an opening
statement or a closing argument without
notes because you know the case you
don't need notes but the problem is
there's certain things you have to say
there's certain points you have to make
otherwise you jeopardize your client's
rights because hey you didn't say i hope
you forgot to say that
and it's in a situation like this
there's nothing you have to say
there's no magic word that must be
uttered
all you have to do is talk
all you have to do is talk in a way that
inspires
the fan base the media and any players
who may be watching
what you say doesn't mean jack diddly
squat
chris i'm astounded by this these are
not
mom and pop operations even though
they're they're owned by family
businesses
these are billion dollar companies where
are the consultants
where are the specialists where are the
people
who would help nick ciriani rehearse
that press conference where are the
people that would go to nick casario and
say nick
nick you're gonna wait you're gonna
you're not gonna read from that piece of
paper are you
that doesn't even exist in the nfl that
doesn't exist
isn't it amazing there i know i know but
why are they that
cheap are they that cheap yes
yes they don't have people that you know
know sky judge they don't want people
there to check the inflation of the
football
and keep down on all those things yes
it's all crooked
like my middle finger not that i'm
showing you my middle finger but my
middle finger's crossed
you're right mike i mean but but i i
think too
i'll give a little leeway into this
first off
not everybody's as comfortable as you
and i sitting in front of this camera i
resent you saying that we're not that
talented okay
not everybody's uncomfortable with a big
mouth and being
i know you're not i'm willing to do it
i'm not i know you're not
and but you know coaches
can be a little different that way as
weird as that is that's why i don't ever
judge too harshly with that even though
this was a very
awkward moment there's no denying that
but his wheelhouse
is coaching football and talking to
football
players yeah this was outside of his
wheelhouse it wasn't a good look
certainly and i mean i i found it
laughable
and i don't mean to be disrespectful to
coach siriani because i actually like a
lot of the things he does on the
as far as offense and what he believes
but i just found it laughable that he's
talking about
we need smart people and there he is
fumbling with note cards and
we want to play fast because we don't
have to think and there he is thinking
about his note cards where i want to go
you're truly
like almost talking out of both sides of
your mouth about the message you're
trying to send and then the message
you're actually
giving us which was just crazy in itself
but i'm not going to judge too harshly
here
he is a young guy it wasn't a great look
i have more questions
rather than that i want to go what the
hell is going to go on with the
quarterback situation
how the hell is this going to play out
where's carson wentz
and i'm i'm still you know we talk about
houston a lot but i want to know what
the hell is going to go on in
philadelphia they got a lot of question
marks there
and and that's the other side of this i
think the colts were the team that you
didn't mention earlier when we were live
you're right that's how we've staffed
sean watson but but carson wentz could
end up in indianapolis but siriani comes
in as the guy who's
the right-hand man of frank reich but
then they hire a quarterback's coach
who's known jalen hurts
most of jalen hurt's life so it is a
strange situation but chris you you make
a good point
that that's related to something else
that i want to shed light on after the
prepared remarks portion of the press
conference ends
these guys are operating without a net
they're asked questions they have to
answer them extemporaneously
and it's just talking that's the thing
it's just talking and it astounds me
you say it's not nick sirioni's
wheelhouse it astounds me
that he can get into a locker room in
front of a bunch of football players who
are all
looking at him wondering what's he going
to say and how are they going to react
and are some going to roll their eyes
and are some going to be talking among
themselves
how do you command that room comfortably
and not command
a zoom video conference or a room full
of quarters
i it's i i just i don't get it and and
look
you and i have experience the more you
do it the easier it gets
and it's not like head coaches do a lot
of introductory press conferences
but that's all the more reason to write
the check
to the local consulting firm that will
come in and spend
four or five hours working with nick
ceriani to get him to a point where he
goes out and he delivers
a clear cogent and persuasive message
that lets everyone know
this guy gets it hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports